da sind ganz viele nazis ist das war
bestimmt wäre keine nazis die
allermeisten wir sind aus der mitte der
gesellschaft ich bin ein fdp mitglied
der alternativen deutschland
[Musik]
mainstream presse hier keine berichte
weil die deutsche presse nicht
überwiegend falls mainstream und hat
bestimmte politische vorbehalte gegen
alles was vermeintlich rechts ist wir
haben uns eine simple lassen mission von
ihre drinnen und gesagt er hat sie's wir
sind nazis sie sind nazis nein das denke
ich nicht ich denke russia today ist
objektiv unsere unsere presse
das sind die verräter und ein schönes
gegengewicht zu unseren
gleichgeschalteten medien zu unserem
startpunkt der uns jahre manipuliert
da sind ganz viele nazis ist das war
bestimmt wird keine nazis die
allermeisten wir sind aus der mitte der
gesellschaft ich bin afd mitglied der
alternativen vorschlagen oder ist weder
hooligans noch rechtsradikal
wir stehen hier auch für die leute und
deren kinder
ja sie irgendwann meinen frieden groß
werden sollen in frieden groß werden
sollen das nochmal aus dem gleichen
grunde wie ihr ja ich habe angst davor
dass die salafisten die easy ist hier
von drüben rüberkommt in uns einen job
abstände unseren kindern uns nicht islam
gläubige nächsten nicht mehr fremd dass
sie herkommen machen die deutschen
renten sind nicht mehr gesichert wie man
dann nachher gehen kann und jeden
ausländer rein nimmt auch die
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge nicht nur die
kriegsflüchtlinge der islam in ried
macht der sagen wir punkt sagen wir auch
punkt macht der macht der islam renten
kaputt in der masse wer sich anbietet
und wie er kommt und wir noch kommen
wird in den kommenden jahren macht
natürlich der islam logischerweise
volkswirtschaftliche rechnung die rente
kaputt keine frage wenn jemand die
kriminelle gehört auto klaut oder jemand
körperverletzung aufnehmen raus haben
sie schon mal persönlich ein schicksal
erlebt konserven auto gebaut worden weil
er selber ein islamist nein
ich mache keinen unterschied zwischen
den deutschen politikern
für mich sind die alle gleich sofort
eilen würden sie gerne unser kanzler
sein
grundsätzlich ja der radikale islamist
stimmung
ja der ist 100 mal schlimmer als jetzt
stadion vor homosexuellen damit gebe ich
mit diesem sehr schönen worten gewicht
zurück nach moskau